well as I understand it they're doing
that for the office of the presidency
for future presidents I think it's very
important precedent and the attorneys
say that they're not doing that for me
they're doing that for the office of the
president so we're talking about the
future let me be clear dom again doesn't
testify it is time to open an
impeachment inquiry so that was
President Trump on his way up to
Pennsylvania this evening for a rally
talking about the latest back and forth
between the White House and the Congress
over Don Magan there you see him on the
screen the former White House Counsel
Pat's a Bologna the White House Counsel
writing a letter to chairman Jerrold
Nadler of the House Judiciary Committee
saying quote the Department of Justice
has advised me that mr. McGann is
absolutely immune from compelled
congressional testimony with respect to
matters occurring during his service as
a senior advisor to the president
because of this constitutional immunity
in order to protect the prerogatives of
the office of the presidency the
president has directed mr. McGann not to
appear at the committee scheduled
hearing on Tuesday May 21st
in other words tomorrow let's bring in
our panel byron york chief political
correspondent washington examiner Susan
page Washington bureau chief at USA
Today and Katie Pavlich news editor at
townhall comm panel welcome Katie your
thoughts on the latest on the back and
forth well the White House statement was
clearly more political than the DOJ
state memo that they released but the 15
pages that the department justice did
release prove that they're ready for a
long term court battle over the specific
issue with Jerry Nadler the chairman of
the Judiciary Committee wanting to call
direct staff members and senior advisors
to the president up to testify the White
House emphasized again today the Dom
McGann testified for 30 hours to the
special counsel pointed out they've
turned over 1.4 million documents to the
special counsel and they're framing this
as we're not going to give Jerry Nadler
a redo of the Moller investigation but
based on the things that the 15 page
memo stated about precedent under
different administration's those
Republicans and Democrats citing the
Clinton administration and the Nixon
administration they're clearly looking
at this
from a broader perspective and arguing
that this is not just about this
administration but that previous senior
advisors to the White House have been
protected by by this by the precedent
that the DOJ has set and not being
forced to comply with these subpoenas
because it's a direct adviser to the
president
Susan we heard from David Cicilline
who's a member of the leadership team
and he used the I word impeachment your
thoughts and where we are right now well
in this case the Trump administration is
building on an arc line of argument that
was made by the Obama administration now
there's some mixed history on this under
the Bush W George W Bush administration
it was a Court decision that said that
the that Harriet Miers would have to go
comply with the subpoena and go up and
appear before a congressional panel but
they are in line was with some
presidency but this is part of a broad
effort by the Trump administration to
defy congressional investigations on
every front and that is enormous ly
frustrating to the House Democratic
Chairman and it does fuel the desire by
some House Democrats to move forward
with impeachment one of those fronts is
trying to get the president's tax
returns take a listen to his answer on
this we disagree with that ruling it's
crazy because you look at it this never
happened to any other president they're
trying to get a redo they're trying to
get what we used to call in school a
deal a do-over and if you look you know
we had no collusion we had no
obstruction we had no nothing
being from New Jersey I'm familiar with
the term do over but Byron your thoughts
on where we stand tonight on one trying
to get McGann up to the hill and two on
the financial records the financial
records thing that was it's not this tax
return is the financial records from his
accounting firm and I think he was going
to lose that it's not a really they
didn't have a really strong argument the
White House said well Congress doesn't
have a legitimate legislative purpose in
getting this information in the judge I
think is not going to tell Congress what
its legislative purpose is on the McGann
thing I think it's a little different I
think the White House is on pretty solid
ground here they did cite events from
the Clinton administration from the
George W Bush administration
and from Obama in these are cases I
think in which they really don't want to
go to court I don't think they want a
decision get the both sides Congress and
the White House would have a lot to lose
in this especially in the in the bush
case the Congress subpoenaed Harriet
Miers
who was at White House Counsel and Karl
Rove in 2007 they bickered about it for
two years into the Obama administration
finally they agreed to go talk but was
extreme limitations it had to be only on
the subject that was at hand which was
the firing of a lot of White House the
US Attorney's and they would not talk
about any conversation they had had with
the president now if Don began goes
under those conditions the Democrats
will be very very unhappy
of course these fights are not happening
in a political vacuum you got the
president going up to battleground
Pennsylvania tonight you got 20-plus
Democrats running for president what
about the politics of this well politics
of this on the campaign trail are that
people don't really care about this
issue people in New Hampshire in Iowa
and Michigan and Wisconsin where
Democrats are trying to take back voters
who were Democrats who voted for Trump
Russia and and president Trump's tax
returns which he didn't release during
the 2016 election are not at the top of
their list with back in Washington it is
helpful to Democrats who are running for
president for Democrats on the hill to
be subpoenaing information to try and
embarrass the president to make him look
like he's not complying or if he's not
complying with these subpoenas to make
him look like he's hiding something that
will be politically helpful to them when
it comes to a general election for them
to do the opposition research through
their positions on these committees
while the candidates are out there
talking about issues and meeting with
voters your thoughts on the politics you
know I think I agree with you that this
isn't what at the top of voters Minds
you talked to voters they say health
care education things that involve their
their own lives but among the strongest
Democratic activists they do care about
holding the president accountable about
being able to investigate him by doing
the kind of oversight that Republicans
declined to do during the first two
years of his tenure when they control
both houses of Congress and that creates
I think it's some risks for Democratic
leaders because do they how do they
manage that that desire to investigate
the president against that their
knowledge that the issues that really
motivate voters or something else here's
some fresh reaction from Donegan's
attorney William Burke saying that he
will respect the president's instruction
about not testifying tomorrow tomorrow
Byron what about the politics of the
moment well this will go on I think I
think that this lack of interest among
the voters and we've got a Muller report
it was 450 pages long there's a lot of
information in it and it hasn't seemed
to change a lot of minds I think
Democrats and they're pretty open about
this they realized that most people
didn't dig into the Mulder report
there's arcane legal argument there's a
lot of details in there I think they
would like to create a simple TV show
out of it to have a dramatic witness
come and testify in front of Congress
and maybe they could get some
interesting personal information out of
it and it could be a show that people
could actually attach themselves to
that's why they want McGann to testify
so badly and they certainly like to get
Robert and Muller as well and I think
that's one of the reasons the the White
House is resisting you have to remember
began cooperated entirely with the
criminal proceeding that is the Muller
investigation dirty pages excuse me 30
hours of testimony tons of pages of
material it's just the White House does
not want to let them create this TV show
then there's Michigan congressman Justin
Amash who's a libertarian kind of guy
has you know a tendency to butt heads
with his leadership calling for
impeachment now a Twitter back and forth
between Amash and President Trump over
impeachment Katie your thoughts on this
well Republicans aren't known for being
in lockstep which is a good thing not
having groupthink but when it comes to
Justin Amash --is past positions on
civil liberties which have been good
ones I find it quite interesting that he
took the position of impeachment when
there is so much evidence on the other
side of this situation of the FBI
improperly using that the Justice
Department and the DNC and the Clinton
found or the Clinton campaign to go
after a political opponent with the
federal government of course we all
we've talked about the the potential of
the FISA abuse so after reading the
report as many of us have I think a lot
of people and Republicans have been
saying on Capitol Hill today we have
come to a very different conclusion and
we do
agree with the calls for impeachment by
congressman Amash but he is entitled to
his opinion and certainly president
Trump has an opinion about it as well
Speaker Nancy Pelosi told our producer
Jason Donner on the hill just moments
ago that they really need some
bipartisanship in the Senate really to
go anywhere with impeachment but your
thoughts I mean that's her standard has
been they shouldn't go forward with
impeachment if there's not bipartisan
support Justin Amash does not comprise
bipartisan support for impeach what he
speaks only for himself but there's one
way in which he could create big
problems for Donald Trump and that is if
he runs as the libertarian nominee for
president he says that's a possibility
and you know we know that he company
comes from a key state we know that
third-party candidates do not have to
get a lot of the vote to put to
potentially affect the outcome in a
state in a key state like Michigan that
could matter briefly pratik hope would
be that this could be a crack in the dam
the beginning of something that would
build into something much much bigger
does not appear to be that happening at
all and of course the bigger issue of
course is the Senate and Mitt Romney for
goodness sakes said he did not agree
with Justin Amash here so they're not
seeing any progress for Democrats in the
Senate on this an action-packed panel
thank you very much